a lot of people would call valerian a cs
go clone but what really makes the game
unique are its agents
30 seconds grass one's grass leaf leave
a lot of grass we're splitting c's
putting c
for example duelists like jet and reyes
add a verticality to the game that's
totally different from other tactical
shooters i'm going to try flying knife
him
okay show us shows
10 seconds left
since launch just about every top player
has gravitated towards these agents and
when euro came out people were hyped
one enemy remains
eight
send five more we can do this again
yeah but q racks hypoch how do they
clear him out let's see if they check on
him they do but they can't beat him
that's lovely but
they don't know how to deal with it ep
is perfect
but the excitement surrounding yoru
didn't last
and then there's yoru
doesn't have anything
and he just exists
now get out of jail free card no utility
to support it i think yuru
i think it's important that he's down
here because i think yoru might have the
worst flash in the game you think about
maniaru no he's not good
i am not having fun yoru went from being
one of the most exciting agents in
valoran to basically a meme
but is he really as bad as everyone says
or are they just playing him wrong
[Music]
hey everyone before we get into the
video i just wanted to let you know that
we worked with bose to create their new
rule the quiet videos following key
storylines of worlds here's a sneak peek
my name is andre odom nepasco and i'm
the top laner for rogue the way i find
my piece before the games or before big
matches just by listening to music i
give myself in a good mindset where it's
just me and my thoughts i'm alone and i
can fully focus on the game that's ahead
of me so that i put in my best
performance if i'm looking for something
to get myself hyped up for the game i
have something for that and i also have
a playlist that i listen to when i try
to get myself to meditate or just calm
down
check out the link below for more world
of quiet videos and thanks to bose for
sending over these awesome quietcomfort
earbuds all right back to yours
back in january valerian received a
massive update that added a new battle
pass and a few competitive changes to
the game but most importantly it
introduced yoru a new duelist who
everyone wanted to get their hands on he
had a fake footstep ability unique
flashes that only popped when they
bounced off a surface and his alt made
him temporarily invulnerable all of this
sounded pretty awesome but what really
drew people to yoru was how cool he
looked he's cool he's cool he has the
little eyebrow slash you know like it
like he's he's cool man and i think he
like the hand signs he throws when he
does his abilities also is cool
everything about the agent's soulmate i
remember i was so hyped watching the
trailer with him coming out like he
looked
so badass but the most interesting part
of yoru's kit and the reason most of
your favorite pros briefly made him was
his teleport ability in theory the
teleport let you take aggressive peaks
get a kill and get out without much risk
everyone was dying to get their hands on
an agent that could dash away after a
kill like jet and yoru was the closest
thing plus he had flashes so the
possibilities seemed almost endless at
the very beginning you know throwing
your teepee at them and then just having
it kind of float behind them and then
just throwing a flash and then blinding
them and keeping behind them was enough
to catch them off guard early on players
like tens cory and ethos showcased what
jorah was capable of on a nightly basis
and it seemed like he was about to
become the game's most popular duelist
what's up
oh my god
holy sh
how did i do that maybe it was just the
excitement of having a new duelist in
the game or maybe people just wanted to
play the cool looking agent but almost
overnight yoru gained a cult-like
following tens for example was really
committed to making the agent work i'm
gonna i'm gonna lurk i wanna be a
slower play style right now i'm actually
gonna legitimately try to play this
character how i think he should be
played
on the right one
oh my god
but over time yoru became predictable
players were no longer falling for his
fake footsteps or his obvious teleport
plays and it's all it was really only
being used to gather information all
yoru really had going for him was his
flash but that wasn't nearly enough to
get him a pick over the other better
duelists in the game and once valran's
first international land rolled around
things only got worse
team vikings decided to pick the
japanese agent when they were playing
against team liquid and it completely
backfired on them we're gonna see the
dimensional drift used trying to clear
out some of those spots and maybe give
them a reposition to actually retake
from another angle it will give another
spot but it doesn't matter soulcast has
already found another with the shot dart
they've also got the denial of the push
back in the nano swarm gonna hold them
back even further and this map is
looking done vikings have got to go back
to the drawing board on that we've seen
the first yoru come out here in masters
and maybe the last based on how it uh
how it played out
i mean we had a plan we knew that they
would they were going to pick sage and
cersei's kind of weakness
so it was a way to counter it
uh but
it didn't work out like it's like you
saw right
what's the plan for sure but despite his
failures on the world stage the true
yoru fans weren't willing to let him go
and it seemed like riot wasn't going to
let him die either when they buffed his
flash in a patch back in march tens cory
and ethos were still trying to make him
work but everyone else just saw yoru as
a troll pick so when tens locked in yoru
against sonics and the qualifiers for
masters berlin it was quite the surprise
is playing
i must
forget about every other agent cop pick
tens is playing yours somebody sounds
some kind of alarm sentinels went on to
win the match but tens didn't have much
impact and when he picked the agent
again the following week against genji
they lost sentinels threw an 8-0 lead
and sure tens showed off some cool plays
using yoru's alt and a shorty but you
have to imagine he could have done more
on basically any other agent since that
loss sentinel's igl shazam hasn't
allowed tens to pick yoru again and he's
basically forced him back onto the reina
pick that has rarely failed them i think
that gyoru shouldn't be in the hands of
someone like tens because tens is so
good he did he needs to be on like right
now like his impact with generating is
insane after seeing one of the best
players in the world struggle to make an
impact on yoru everyone agreed that the
agent was just bad a small group of
dedicated yoru fans remained but when
they begged riot to make changes to him
they were ignored
yoru's pick rate plummeted and riot
basically gave up on him admitting that
they won't be doing anything else to the
agent anytime soon because even they
don't know what to do
and to be fair balancing a game like
valrant can be an absolute nightmare one
small change can turn an entire meta on
its head so buffing yoru isn't as easy
as it sounds do we really want another
jet
riot has faced their fair share of
criticism over the years for pushing
meta altering updates right before big
events in league of legends so maybe
they've learned their lesson and won't
touch him until after champions in
december
but when riot does decide to give yoru
the buff he so desperately needs where
do they even start
most players think his fake footsteps
are completely useless now and his
ultimate doesn't really make sense for
an agent that's supposed to be a duelist
so with two lackluster abilities is riot
just going to rework his entire kit
that's something they do all the time in
league of legends but it isn't something
they've tried and valor it just yet and
maybe improving the flash maybe making
it pop faster or maybe making it harder
to hear would be good
maybe making that tp go faster maybe
making the tp quieter or maybe making
the tp just you know quieter as it moves
and then only making it louder as it you
know once it like starts to stabilize
you might be wondering why any of this
matters after all you could just let you
die out riot is just going to make newer
better agents and they'll fill the role
he was supposed to
well for one having a useless character
sucks in any game but more importantly
valor still has a huge jet problem and a
better yoru might be a way to fix that
jet topped the charts at master 3 in
berlin she had an 85 pick rate with
players like yay and defoe showing just
how busted she still is fundamentally
jet is still the only agent you can use
an operator with and although they
recently nerfed her by removing one of
her smokes and changing the right click
on her alt jet's ability to run around
and kill people with the off is
ridiculous the main problem with her kit
is her tailwind ability and riot still
refuses to acknowledge this no other
agent can get away with the same kind of
aggressive peaks a jet cam
the op is only viable in jet and that's
a problem in my opinion it's too clunky
to use on any other agent and the
problem is is that there's no there's
not a lot of counter options to the up
now if you could use the op on other
agents you can counter a jet just
walking up with an opera or a jet just
taking a duel at dry peak unless ryan
buffs agents like yoru to compete with
jet she's still gonna be the only
duelist that really matters until then
jet and even reina are gonna continue to
run free reigning terror on everybody
but who knows maybe one day a buffed
yoru will appear to save us all
i guess looking forward guys just have
faith have faith your isn't
you're always always going to be this
little puppy that you guys can just look
down on um
your roommates rise off
all right i got it you can sit back
okay i took over
are you taking over
for one of us
oh
help me
i should do my flash a little earlier